m
la 3è journées partenariales de l'action
sociale s'est déroulée au tampon une
journée de rencontres et d'échangés
organisée par les travailleurs sociaux
et leurs partenaires autour
d'engagements les plus innovants
aujourd'hui on va rassembler plus de 200
partenaires déboires 250 travailleurs
sociaux médico-sociaux donc une belle
journée parce que ça répond
effectivement à une attente forte de
l'ue terrain qui est de pouvoir
justement non dans le cadre de ces
journées partager des idées partager des
pratiques et puis aussi partagé sur les
boules les actions innovantes dans le
champ d'action sociale tout au long de
la journée ont été proposés des ateliers
d'été bat ou encore des animations qui
ont permis le partage d'expériences sur
des thématiques essentielles pour
l'action sociale
alors c'est un atelier qui a été re
fait avec les jeunes
de notre service qui sont pris en charge
dans le cadre de la zone est un travail
partenarial avec les actions de santé
alors aujourd'hui nous proposons un
atelier sur la déficience visuelle
une cour de nombreuses exactement
laquelle il sur la déficience gel avec
différents partenaires avec lesquels
nous travaillons
régulièrement dans le domaine de la
déficience visuelle comme le
un établissement médico-social samsa dv
qui ré autonomise les adultes handicapés
déficients visuels
le centre de rééducation russe qui
rééduque les personnes qui ont perdu par
seconde dans la vue
et l'association voulons un oui de
prométhée avait h de la réunion des
indiens qui est une association au
service des personnes aveugles et
malvoyantes
français à la réunion et dans le sens le
diable cette journée a permis aux
professionnels d'échanger de mieux se
connaître mais surtout de rendre
l'action auprès de la population plus
efficace tant humainement que
socialement
l'atelier va concerner la guidances
parentale pour les personnes en
situation de handicap visuel
là l'idée c'est justement expliqué que
ces personnels sont parents comme tout
parent c'est pas c'est pas de
revendiquer le fait de pouvoir va
pouvoir c'est juste en fait quoi la
ville est dehors
les deux relais dans la nature et
comment il peut mettre tout ce monde-là
ans sans poils est vraiment points mieux
et faire un jardin où tout le monde me
retrouve à zot lé aidant les aider les
personnes âgées les médecins les
travailleurs sociaux les familles pour
aller vers la vie et que dire que en
sang tout le monde peut il peut avancer
il peut trouver une solution au cours de
ces journées partenariales de l'action
sociale le conseil départemental a
souhaité mettre en place des stands
visant à faire connaître ses équipements
culturels ainsi que ces directions
thématiques
alors c'est une occasion effectivement
privilégier pour pouvoir non seulement
rencontré ni au public parce qu'il ya
quand même un certain nombre d'étudiants
qui sont dépassés qui sont venus
aujourd'hui pour lui demander à ces
temps de l'information mais également
nos partenaires nos collègues
partenaires dans le domaine du social et
on est souvent confronté à des
situations un peu particulière notamment
au niveau des étudiants qui sont en
rupture familiale qui sont en difficulté
sociale et donc l'eau il ya une certaine
relation qui ce qui se met en place
entre nos services instructeurs de 10 de
cette bosse et nos collègues partenaires
qui travaillent sur dans le monde social
on est venu ici pour présenter nos
offres nous bâtir des offres et les
passations qu'on présente finalement
possible d'intégrer justement et tous
les équipements du conseil général à
notre
à notre exposition de ce que l'on nous
offre que nous présentons des hommes
c'est naturel je trouve que c'est
important puisque finalement les quand
même assez très isolées ou éloignées
on reçoit du public et des scolaires est
de plus en plus on a besoin d'échanger
pour connaître aussi et ce service qui
existe conseil général et par ce biais
justement d'aujourd'hui ça nous
permettra de pouvoir travailler avec les
uns et les autres personnes qui sont ici
la dernière journée partenariale de
l'action sociale se déroulera à l'espace
réglée du bas de la rivière à saint
denis